This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Happy National Train Day, everyone. For those who missed it, it was May 13th this year. How do I know that? Mainly because 99Pi's resident train, aficionado, Kurt Colestead keeps reminding all of us. Because I love trains, okay? It's also the one year anniversary of our first collection of stories entirely about trains.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。祝大家全国火车日快乐。对于那些错过的人，今年的全国火车日是5月13日。我怎么知道的？主要是因为《99%隐形》的常驻火车迷库尔特·科尔斯泰德一直在提醒我们所有人。因为我喜欢火车，行吗？这也是我们第一个完全关于火车的系列故事集的一周年纪念日。
We called it Trainset Track 1. And to the surprise of no one, I had more than one episode's worth of train story ideas, even before 99Pi fans started writing in with more ideas. So Track 1 gave way to Track 2, and now here we are for the final part of our train factory. Trainset Track 3. gave way to track 2 and now here we are for the final part of our train factory. Trainset Track 3. Greetings passengers, this is your conductor speaking. Our first out today is the fictional island of Sodor.
我们称之为“火车集：第一轨”。不出所料，我拥有的火车故事创意远不止一集的内容，甚至在《99%隐形》的粉丝们写信提供更多点子之前就是这样。所以“第一轨”让位于“第二轨”，现在我们来到了我们火车工厂的最后一部分。“火车集：第三轨”。各位乘客请注意，我是你们的列车长。我们今天的第一站是虚构的索多岛。
In the late 1980s, I first encountered Shining Time Station, which was this mesmerizing animated show that played during primetime on PBS. Reach for the speed, reach for the whistle, go where the rail may run. Reach for the words, reach for the story, follow the rainbow's side. The show debuted when I was four years old. At the time, my family lived in this little red brick farmhouse in upstate New York, and like a lot of households in the 80s, ours didn't have cable.
在20世纪80年代末，我第一次接触到《闪耀时光车站》，这是一档在公共电视网（PBS）黄金时段播出的迷人动画节目。“追求速度，追求汽笛，去往铁轨延伸的地方。追求文字，追求故事，追随彩虹的边缘。”该节目首播时我才四岁。当时，我们一家住在纽约州北部的一座红色小砖农舍里，像80年代的许多家庭一样，我们家没有有线电视。
So when my brother and I got to watch TV, we watched a lot of households in the 80s, ours didn't have cable. So when my brother and I got to watch TV, we watched a lot of PBS. And in the era of less sophisticated animation, this shows Claymation was mesmerizing. I was enchanted by the charming characters, the backdrop of verdant rolling hills laced with locomotive tracks, and of course, its's breakaway star.
所以当我和哥哥看电视时，我们看了很多公共电视网的节目。在那个动画技术还不那么成熟的时代，这部剧的粘土动画令人着迷。我被那些迷人的角色、点缀着火车轨道的翠绿起伏的山丘背景，当然还有它那横空出世的明星所吸引。
Thomas the Tank Engine. Thomas is a tank engine, who lives at a big station on the island of Sodor. He's a cheeky little engine with six small wheels, a short stumpy funnel, a short stumpy boiler, and a short stumpy dome. Its early seasons were narrated by none other than musician Sir Richard Starchy, better known to the world by his stage name. From a beetle ring a star is among the show's cast and talked with reporters in New York. I love kids I used to be one.
托马斯小火车。托马斯是一辆坦克机车，住在索多岛上的一个大车站里。他是一辆厚脸皮的小火车，有六个小轮子，一个短粗的烟囱，一个短粗的锅炉，和一个短粗的圆顶。它的早期剧集由音乐家林戈·斯塔尔担任旁白，他在世界范围内更广为人知的艺名是……来自披头士乐队的林戈·斯塔尔是该剧演员阵容的一员，并曾在纽约接受记者采访。我爱孩子，因为我曾经也是个孩子。
In this cartoon world, anthropomorphized trains chug chug chug along the picturesque countryside of this hilly bright and colorful island. The stop-motion animation makes the series feel rich and three-dimensional. As a kid, that's what I saw, an inocuous series about trains. But decades later, I read this essay by Gia Tolentino with a fun upbeat title. The repressive authoritarian soul of Thomas the Tank Engine Anfamous. So I know a lot of children's shows have many levels of meaning so that they can have
在这个卡通世界里，拟人化的火车在这座多山、明亮且色彩斑斓的岛屿上风景如画的乡村中“哐当哐当”地行驶。定格动画让这个系列看起来丰富且具有立体感。作为一个孩子，我看到的就是这些，一个关于火车的无害系列。但几十年后，我读到了贾·托伦蒂诺写的一篇标题欢快有趣的文章：《托马斯小火车的压抑威权灵魂》。所以我知道很多儿童节目都有多层含义，这样它们就可以为观看的家长们提供一些小笑话。
little jokes for the parents who might be watching. Is that what you're talking about at these subtle dark jokes? Yeah, that's part of it, but it also runs much deeper and goes all the way back to the origin of this fictional world. Shining Time Station and its characters grew out of a series of books that were published in the 1940s and were written by Anglican Minister Wilbert Audrey. He started out by telling train stories to his son Christopher who was ill and bed bound and then those started to become the basis for books.
你是说那些微妙的黑暗笑话吗？是的，那是其中的一部分，但它也更深层，一直追溯到这个虚构世界的起源。《闪耀时光车站》及其角色源于20世纪40年代出版的一系列书籍，由圣公会牧师威尔伯特·奥德里撰写。他最初是给生病卧床的儿子克里斯托弗讲火车故事，后来这些故事成为了书籍的基础。
Well, so far that's not so dark, just telling train stories to his sick son. Yeah, it sounds really nice, but Audrey had this very make the British Empire great again, by, and like many a grumpy old man, he lamented the trajectory of his era. In particular, he was a big fan of the 19th century, and he launched for the time in those pesky 1900 troubles like class consciousness and civil rights and post-colonialism started to pervade his precious society. So to get around all of that, he set his stories on this imaginary island off the coast of England, which was a magical place untouched by all of this post-war progressiveness. So how did that manifest? Like how did Audrey's mid-century worldview
嗯，到目前为止这还不算太黑暗，只是给生病的儿子讲火车故事。是的，听起来确实很美好，但奥德里有一种非常“让大英帝国再次伟大”的心态，像许多脾气暴躁的老人一样，他哀叹自己时代的轨迹。特别是，他是19世纪的忠实粉丝，他渴望那个时代，而不是那些令人讨厌的20世纪的麻烦，比如阶级意识、民权和后殖民主义开始渗透进他珍视的社会。为了避开这一切，他把故事设定在英国海岸外的一个虚构岛屿上，那是一个未受所有这些战后进步主义影响的魔法之地。那么这是如何体现的呢？奥德里那世纪中叶的世界观是如何从他的书一直传到你看到的那个80年代卡通节目的？
make its way from his books all the way to that 1980s cartoon show that you saw? Well, to be clear, the entire train Utopia he envisioned was really a dystopia by almost any standard, a really disturbing place where the demands on these cute anthropomorphized train characters are often excessive and unreasonable, and the punishments for disobeying are strangely severe.
好吧，明确一点，他设想的整个火车乌托邦实际上按照任何标准来看都是一个反乌托邦，一个非常令人不安的地方，对这些可爱的拟人化火车角色的要求往往是过分且不合理的，而对违抗者的惩罚则异常严厉。
That sounds nightmare-ish. Can you give us an example? Yeah, there are tons of examples of how strange this is. In some episodes you see sentient vehicles being outright murdered, just crushed or ripped apart, dismembered effectively, and often for pretty minor offences. One of the most vivid and horrifying examples I found is in this episode called The Sad Story of Henry. And it starts off whimsically enough with an engine named Henry who gets a spiffy new paint job and he wants to shelter it from the rain as it dries off. Makes sense, right?
这听起来像噩梦一样。你能给我们举个例子吗？是的，关于这有多奇怪的例子数不胜数。在一些剧集中，你会看到有知觉的车辆被直接谋杀，被压碎或撕裂，实际上是被肢解，而且往往是因为一些相当小的罪行。我发现的最生动、最恐怖的例子之一是在这一集《亨利的悲伤故事》中。它开始时相当异想天开，一辆名叫亨利的火车得到了一个漂亮的新漆面，它想在油漆变干时躲避雨水。这说得通，对吧？
Once an engine attached to a train was afraid of a few drops of rain. It went into a tunnel and squeaked through its funnel and wouldn't come out again. So Henry comes to a stop in this railway tunnel and refuses to move. Eventually the big boss, Sir Topham Hat, comes along and has his hints been tried to push and pull Henry out of the tunnel. When that fails in the train still won't move, he declares that they will strip away the train tracks out from under Henry and break off the tunnel permanently. We shall take away your rails, he said, and leave you here for always and always and always.
“曾经有一辆挂在火车上的机车害怕几滴雨。它开进了一条隧道，在烟囱里吱吱作响，再也不肯出来。”所以亨利停在了这条铁路隧道里，拒绝移动。最终，大老板托帕姆·哈特爵士来了，让他的手下试图推拉亨利出隧道。当尝试失败，火车仍然不动时，他宣布他们将拆掉亨利身下的铁轨，并永久封死隧道。“我们要拆掉你的铁轨，”他说，“把你永远、永远、永远地留在这里。”
They took up the old rails and built a wall in front of him so that, then we couldn't get out of the tunnel anymore. He was very sad because he thought no one would ever see his lovely green paint with red stripes again. Okay, wait. So, for the crime of taking shelter in a storm so his paint wouldn't run They basically in prison Henry for life inside of a tunnel. Yeah, they walled him alive Which is straight up out of a horror film, right? And he goes through this disturbing mix of facial expressions as the walls are stacking up around him brick by brick It's like he's frightened but also confused.
他们拆掉了旧铁轨，在他面前筑起了一堵墙，这样他就再也出不来隧道了。他非常难过，因为他以为再也没有人能看到他那可爱的带有红色条纹的绿色油漆了。好吧，等等。所以，仅仅因为在暴风雨中避雨以免油漆脱落的罪名，他们就把亨利终身监禁在隧道里？是的，他们把他活埋了，这简直就像恐怖电影里的情节，对吧？当砖块一砖一砖地在他周围堆砌起来时，他经历了一种令人不安的面部表情混合，看起来既害怕又困惑。
The whole thing is just awful. And then they go on to describe Henry's friends passing by on adjacent tracks. One of them shouts a greeting, but another callously remarks that Henry got what he deserved. Meanwhile, for his part, Henry can't even respond to them. Paul Henry had no steam to answer. His fire had go out. Which I'm not really sure how to interpret, like did he starve to death? That's really creepy if so. Or even worse, maybe trans can't die.
整件事简直太可怕了。然后他们继续描述亨利的朋友们在相邻的轨道上经过。其中一个大声打招呼，但另一个冷酷地评论说亨利是罪有应得。与此同时，亨利甚至无法回应他们。“可怜的亨利没有蒸汽来回答。他的火已经熄灭了。”我不太确定该如何解读这一点，他是饿死了吗？如果是这样的话，那真的很诡异。或者更糟的是，也许火车根本死不了。
So he's just internal purgatory, forever with no fire to go anywhere. The last line in the scene is especially chilling. With Ringo Starr asking this leading question. But I think he deserved his punishment. Don't you? No, I don't. Actually, I don't. I'm gonna, I suppose there's a kind of a message here for kids about listening to their parents or something, but oh my god. Yeah, now the punishment seems so far out of proportion to the infraction, and I
所以他只是处于永恒的炼狱中，没有火去任何地方。这一幕的最后一句台词特别令人不寒而栗。林戈·斯塔尔问了这样一个引导性问题：“但我认为他罪有应得。你不觉得吗？”不，我不觉得。实际上，我不觉得。我想这对于孩子们来说可能有一种关于听父母话之类的寓意，但天哪。是的，现在看来惩罚与违规行为相比太不成比例了，我无法相信我小时候是怎么忽略这一点的。
can't believe how I missed this when I was a kid. Okay, well our train journey is off to a very positive and uplifting start. So let's get this train rolling to the next station before we get break into a tomb like poor Henry. 1. Draw the line on the back of the head. 2. Draw the line on the back of the head. 3. Draw the line on the back of the head. Attention passengers, I've just been alerted we need to make an unscheduled stop. Please remain seated at this time. Trains are nothing if not fast and massive, which means that slowing them down on short
好吧，我们的火车之旅以一个非常积极和令人振奋的开端开始。所以让我们在像可怜的亨利那样被关进坟墓之前，让这列火车开往下一站。各位乘客请注意，我刚接到通知，我们需要进行一次计划外的停车。请此时保持就座。火车如果不是又快又重，那就不叫火车了，这意味着在短时间内减速将极其困难。
notice is going to be incredibly difficult. Yeah, like they're not known for being nimble. No, there's a reason that we stop cars and not trains at the train crossing. Right. And so from the start, railways have worked on ways of warning operators far enough in advance if they do need to stop. One popular solution was flags set out on the sides of tracks to warn oncoming trains of dangers ahead. But flags only work when you can see them. And that puts trains in foggy places like the UK in danger. Right. So in the mid 1800s, an English mechanical engineer started to game out potential audible alerts that could be used on even the
是的，就像它们不以灵活著称一样。不，我们在铁路道口停车而不是火车停车是有原因的。对。所以从一开始，铁路部门就一直在研究如何在需要停车时提前足够远地警告操作员。一种流行的解决方案是在轨道两侧设置旗帜，以警告迎面而来的火车前方有危险。但旗帜只有在你看到它们时才有效。这使得像英国这样多雾的地方的火车处于危险之中。对。所以在19世纪中期，一位英国机械工程师开始研究潜在的听觉警报，这些警报可以在即使是雾天也能使用，并且声音大到足以在已经嘈杂的火车上被听到。他想出的解决方案是炸药。
foggy day and would be loud enough to be heard over an already noisy train. And the solution he came up with was explosives. I mean, trains explosives generally don't go well together, right? I mean, yeah, normally, but we're just talking about little explosions here, just powerful enough to make a sound. Okay, well, I guess it's fine then. In the UK, they call these detonators in the US, they're known as torpedoes, and oncoming
我的意思是，火车和炸药通常不会在一起，对吧？我的意思是，是的，通常情况下，但我们这里说的只是小爆炸，威力刚好足以发出声音。好吧，好吧，我想那没问题。在英国，他们称这些为“雷管”，在美国，它们被称为“鱼雷”，迎面而来的火车会直接碾过一组这些东西，它们会发出一连串的巨响，这当然会穿透持续的火车噪音，引起掌舵者的注意。它们听起来基本上是这样的。我的意思是，当你试图混合节目的声音以至于不破坏人们的耳朵时，很难传达出来，但这确实感觉很响。这感觉像是很多东西。是的，这是一个非常响亮的声音。我的意思是，这是一个非常响亮的爆裂声。
trains would just roll over a set of these, they detonate with a series of bangs, and that of course pierces the steady train noise and gets the attention of whoever is at the helm. And they sound basically like this. I mean, it's hard to convey when you're trying to, you know, mix the sound of a show so that doesn't destroy people's ears, but that does feel loud. That feels like that's a lot of stuff. Yeah, it's a pretty loud sound. I mean, it's a very loud crack.
就像鞭炮一样。当然，你知道，如果有建筑工地，那些建筑工人会有一套这些东西，他们可以跑回去。以防有人没收到这条轨道已经关闭的通知，然后火车也会携带这些东西，这样如果火车抛锚了，他们可以派人沿着铁轨回去放置炸药。同样，确保下一个人知道路上有东西。是的，有点像你车坏在路边时放在车后的路边信号弹。
It's like a firecracker. And of course, you know, if there's a construction site, those construction workers will have a set of these that they can run back up. Just in case somebody didn't get the memo that this track is closed down, and then train to carry sets of these two so that if the train breaks down, they can send somebody back up the rails to lay down explosives. And again, make sure that the next guy knows there's something in the way. Yeah, sort of like roadside flares that you put behind your car when you're broken down
是的，完全正确。当人们在铁路上工作时，即使他们不指望有另一列火车过来，他们也可能会放置一些雷管以防万一，对吧？因为“施工中”的标志只能告诉你这么多。如果系统中出现某种人为错误，它只是作为一个很好的备份方式来确保他们会收到消息。当然，这些巨响也帮助了铁路工人，因为如果有迎面而来的火车，他们因为晚上运行安静而没有听到，这意味着为了尊重睡觉的当地人而不使用喇叭和信号，这些工人也会得到一些警报，赶紧离开。
on the side of the road. Yeah, exactly. And when people are working on the rail line, even if they don't expect another train to come, they still might lay down some detonators just in case, right? Because an under construction sign only tells you so much. And if there's some kind of human error in the system, it just serves as a nice backup way to make sure that they're going to get the message. And of course, these bangs help the rail workers too, because if there's an approaching train that they somehow don't hear because it's running quiet at night, meaning it's not using horns and signals out of respect for sleeping locals, these workers get some alert as well to get the heck out of the way.
好吧，我想有备无患总是好的。在这种情况下，安全意味着沿着火车轨道铺设许多小型爆炸装置。绝对的。在到达下一站之前，请检查您面前的座椅靠背，获取您的《吉尼斯世界纪录大全》免费副本。当你想到创纪录的工程奇迹时，通常会想到宏伟的建筑，比如世界上最高的塔或最长的桥。但城市和国家仍然会为在光谱另一端的某种世界纪录称号感到自豪，吹嘘诸如“世界上最短的铁路”之类的事情。
Well, better safe and sorry, I suppose. In this case, it's safe meaning lots of little explosive devices stretched out along a train track. Absolutely. In advance of our next stop, please check the seat back in front of you for your complimentary copy of the Guinness Book of World Records. When you think of record-setting wonders of engineering, usually think of grandfights, like the world's tallest tower or the longest bridge. But cities and countries will still take pride in a world record designation at the
世界各地的一些城镇、城市、城邦和国家都吹嘘自己拥有世界上最短的铁路。但哪一个拥有最合法的权利呢？事实证明，答案不在于火车轨道的实际英寸和英尺，而在于关键术语是如何定义的。在这种情况下，像“短”和“国家”这样的词。古老的《吉尼斯世界纪录大全》将按轨道长度计算的最短火车线路列为英国伯恩茅斯的渔夫步道悬崖铁路缆车。这条小铁路只有128英尺长。与此同时，服务于梵蒂冈城的梵蒂冈铁路似乎是一个非常遥远的第二名，长4200英尺，但他们声称拥有“世界最短国家铁路”的称号，这说得通，因为他们是世界上最小的国家。就在加利福尼亚州，有天使铁路，它在洛杉矶市中心的邦克山运行。每当有人问我在洛杉矶做什么时，我都会让他们去中央市场吃午饭，然后乘坐天使铁路。它有近300英尺长，只有一个街区，车程只有一分钟左右，他们认为这使它成为按持续时间计算的世界上最短的火车。但这不必是一场竞争。就我而言，所有的火车都是好火车，特别是对于今天乘坐私人火车车厢的豪华乘客，我们的下一站将是您选择的城市和州。几年前，我了解到美国铁路公司（Amtrak）提供了一项大多数普通火车用户可能一无所知的服务。
opposite end of the side spectrum, boasting about things like, the world's shortest railway. A number of towns, cities, city-states, and nations around the world brag about being home to the world's shortest railway. A number of towns, cities, city states, and nations around the world brag about being home to the world's shortest train. But which one has the most legitimate claim? It turns out the answer lies not so much in the actual inches and feet of train track, but in how key terms get defined. In this case, words like short and nation. The good old Guinness Book of World Records lists the shortest train line by track length, as the Fisherman's Walk Cliff Railway Fnicular in Bournemouth, England. This wee railway is just 128 feet long. Meanwhile, the Vatican Railway, serving Vatican City, would seem to be a very distant
对于一笔公认的高额费用，他们会将您的私人火车车厢挂在他们已经运营的火车线路上，并拖着您在全国各地行驶。您的私人火车车厢，每个人都有的那种。我的意思是，这听起来绝对豪华，但更像是1800年代的东西，而不是今天的东西。是的，富有的实业家时代。而今天的等价物可能是一架时髦的私人飞机。但在那时，私人火车车厢只是富人可以拥有的东西之一。例如，有这样一辆车，最初是为查尔斯·施瓦布设计和制造的，你可能认出他是一位著名的金融高管。这是一辆非常时髦的交通工具，配得上他名声和财富，有豪华的卧室、浴室等等。当用餐时间到了，你甚至不需要走到餐车。
second at 4,200 feet long, but they claim the title of the World Shortest National Railway, which makes sense because they are the world's smallest nation. And right here in California, there's Angels Flight, which operates on Bunker Hill and downtown Los Angeles. Whenever anyone asks me for something to do in LA, I send them to the Grand Central Market for lunch and then a ride on Angels Flight. It's nearly 300 feet long, just one city block, and the ride only takes about a minute, which they argue makes it the world's shortest train in terms of duration. But it doesn't have to be a competition. As far as I'm concerned, all trains are good trains, especially For Deluxe passengers traveling in private train cars today, our next stop will be the city and state of your choice. A few years back, I learned that Amtrak provides a service that most regular train users probably
这辆车有一个完整的餐厅、厨房和两名员工，包括一名厨师。厨师和乘务员睡在厨房旁边的简陋住处，但施瓦布家族的客人们睡在这些带有木镶嵌的漂亮折叠铺位上。哦，那太好了。里面全是红木。真的，哦，是的。真的很漂亮。它看起来像个图书馆。对，所以你一眼甚至不一定知道它是一辆火车车厢，因为它有所有这些时髦的装饰和这个美妙的燃气系统，
don't know anything about. For an admittedly high fee, they will hook up your private train car onto their train line that they're already operating and tow you around the country. Your private train car, which everyone's happens to have. I mean, that sounds absolutely luxurious, but more like something out of the, you know, the 1800s than, you know, today. Yeah, the error of rich industrialists. And the equivalent today is probably a swank private plane. But back then, a private train car was just one of those things
顺便说一句，几年后它以一种相当复杂的方式进行了升级。这辆车最初是用煤气灯建造的，1912年用地板下电池供电的新型电灯进行了现代化改造。连接到车轴的发电机在车厢沿轨道行驶时为电池充电。我实际上最喜欢这个特定设计的一点是，它实际上不那么显眼，也不是立即可见的。这是一把靠墙放置的椅子，在普通情况下看起来很正常，但如果你抬起座位，下面有一个马桶，如果你拉下座椅靠背，你会发现一个折叠水槽。我的意思是，这太酷了。这似乎是一个放置马桶和水槽的公共场所。
that rich people could own. And there's this one car, for example, that was originally designed and built for Charles Schwab, who you might recognize as a famous financial executive. And it was a seriously posh ride befitting a man of his fame and fortune, with fancy bedrooms and bathrooms and more. When meal time came, you wouldn't even have to walk to the diner.
是的，希望你拥有整辆车。完全正确。是的。所以，好吧，我仍然很难想象它。你是怎么把你那辆花哨的私人火车车厢（我假设它只是存放在某个火车场里）挂到你搭便车的火车后面的？这到底是怎么运作的？完全正确。这就是美国铁路公司（Amtrak）发挥作用的地方，对吧？
This car has a phone dining room, kitchen, and staff of two, including a chef. The chef and steward slept in humble accommodations off the kitchen, but guests of the Schwab family slept in these beautiful, full-down births with wood inlay. Oh, that is nice. That is like all mahogany inside. It's really, oh yeah. Really beautiful. It looks like a library. Right, so you wouldn't even necessarily know it was a train car at a glance, because it has all these posh finishes and this wonderful gas-laden system,
因为只要付费，他们会为你做各种各样的事情。他们会存放你的私人火车车厢。他们会把它挂在沿其路线运行的现有火车上。我发现真正了不起的是，这是一件仍在进行的事情。我的意思是，这听起来像是一件历史性的、时代错误的事情，但这是你今天仍然可以做的事情。
which by the way was upgraded a few years later in a pretty sophisticated way. The car was built with gas lamps and modernized the 1912 with new electric lighting powered by batteries under the floor. Generators connected to the axles recharged the batteries as the car rolled down the rails. And the thing that I actually like the most about this particular design is actually less flashy and not immediately visible. It's this chair that's set up against one wall and it looks normal in off-edic lands, but if you lift the seat, there's a toilet underneath, and if you pull down the seat back, you discover a full-down sink. I mean, that is super cool. It seems like a kind of public place to have your toilet and sink.
就像，罗曼，如果你今天想出去买一辆火车车厢，你可以这样做，然后付钱给美国铁路公司来存放它并拖着你在全国各地行驶。我有点想。我觉得这是一个错失的机会。如果我这样做，我会感觉自己像个镀金时代的男爵，那感觉会很棒。所以跟我说说价格吧。
Yeah, hopefully you've got the whole car to yourself. Exactly. Yeah. So, okay, I'm still having a hard time picturing it. How did you get your fancy private train car, which I assume is just stored in some kind of train yard somewhere onto the back of the train that you're sort of hitching a ride with? Like, how does that work? Exactly. And so that's where Amtrak comes in, right?
现在我真的很好奇，这要花多少钱？嗯，我看到一个细分数据，3000英里的旅程可能花费超过10,000美元。这还不包括你为车厢本身支付的数万美元，或者你租一辆车花费的数千美元。所以私人车厢可能不会很快出现在我的计划中，但幻想一下还是很有趣的。
Because for a fee, they will do all kinds of things for you. They will store your private train car. They will hook it up to an existing train that's running along one of their routes. And what I found really remarkable is that this is a thing that's still ongoing. I mean, it sounds like a historical, an aggritistic thing, but it's something you can still do today.
是的，完全正确。好吧，这太酷了。幻想一下。是的，完全正确。好吧，这太酷了。我有一个新东西要涵盖。我的意思是，拥有我自己的火车车厢并被美国铁路公司拖着穿越全国。这太棒了。我确实希望你在经过明尼阿波利斯时顺便接我。各位乘客请注意。对于那些希望在即将到来的车站下车的乘客，请检查并确保您一开始就登上了正确的车厢。我们认为火车必须在车站开始和停止是理所当然的，对吧？好吧，除非你是《雪国列车》。好吧，是的，然后你就永远走下去直到每个人都死了，但英国人在这一点上遥遥领先。质疑火车是否必须在车站停车。
Like, Roman, if you want to go out today and buy a train car, you can do that and then pay Amtrak to store it and to tow you around the country. I kind of want to. I feel like this is a missed opportunity. I would feel like a, you know, a Gulded Age Baron, if I did this and that would feel pretty awesome. So tell me a little bit about the price.
哦，好吧。是的，所以在19世纪中期，在某些路线上，他们开始使用所谓的“滑行车厢”，这些车厢可以在高速行驶时脱离，然后滑行到给定的车站停止。好吧，所以你得带我了解一下，因为我无法想象它。是的，这有点棘手。
Now I'm really curious, like what is this cost? Well, I saw one breakdown that it could cost over $10,000 for a 3,000 mile trip. And that's on top of the tens of thousands you'd paid for the car itself or the thousands you'd spend a rent one. So a private car probably isn't in the cards for me anytime soon, but it's fun to fantasize about.
基本上，每辆滑行车厢都有指定的工程师。当他们接近目标站点时，那个人会解开链条中的最后一节车厢。然后他们会慢慢地带入并踩下刹车。与此同时，火车的其余部分继续前进。守卫有两个控制装置，滑行杆和刹车。
Yeah, exactly. Well, this is so cool. fantasize about. Yeah, exactly. Well, this is so cool. I have a new thing to cover. I mean, that is having my own train car and traveling across country being pulled by a ham track. That is awesome. I do hope you'll swing by Minneapolis
为了准备滑行，守卫首先必须拆除安全销。就像任何好的铁路换岗时刻一样，它吸引了人群。充其量，准备工作正在进行中以接收滑行车厢。使用他的刹车，守卫将车厢带到了一个平稳的标准位置。我的意思是，即使有工程师在场控制滑行车厢，从高速行驶的火车上脱离似乎也极其微妙。是的，整件事确实有很多活动部件，对吧？所以你可以想象，发生了一些事故。其中一些相当温和，比如车厢在荒郊野外意外滑行，然后人们被困在荒郊野外。但在某些情况下，滑行的车厢实际上会撞到放下它们的火车后面。例如，如果一节车厢被放下，但火车的其余部分必须紧急停车，车厢就会直接撞上火车本身。所以这就是他们停止使用它们的原因吗，比如事故和出错的事情？是的，部分原因，但还有其他因素。一方面，火车越来越快，使得这个过程更加危险，而且滑行车厢是劳动密集型的。不仅每节滑行的车厢都需要自己的工程师，而且当它们被重新接上时，他们还需要人重新连接车厢，滑行只在一个方向上有效。此外，为了使系统工作，乘客必须被锁在他们各自的隔间里。如果他们上了错误的车厢，好吧，当被困在那辆车厢里，等待在错误的车站被滑行时，他们有很长的时间来认真思考他们的错误。你永远猜不到哪个节目花了一整集时间教孩子们那个教训。
and pick me up on your way. Attention passengers. For those wishing to disembark at the upcoming station, please check and make sure you board in the right car to begin with. We take it for granted that trains have to start and stop at stations, right? Well, unless you're the snowpiercer train. Well, yeah, and then you just go on forever until everybody dies, but the Brits were way ahead of the game on this one. Questioning whether
我猜是《托马斯小火车》。对，当然是它。“嘿，注意，确保你进入正确的车厢，那个在你车站停靠的车厢。全员上车。我会用我全新的滑行车厢准时送你到达。”詹姆斯对自己非常满意。和新的滑行车厢。哔！哔！哔！哔！
trains did have to stop at stations. Oh, okay. Yeah, and so back in the mid-18 of the game on this one, questioning whether trains did have to stop at stations. Oh, okay. Yeah, and so back in the mid-1800s, on some routes, they began using what are called slip coaches, which are cars that could be detached at speed and then coast to a stop at a given station. Okay, so you're going to have to walk me through this because I cannot picture it. Yeah, it's kind of tricky.
詹姆斯对自己非常满意。但当然，事情稍微出了点差错，事情升级了。“准备解开后车厢！詹姆斯，在车站不要减速太多，否则最后一节车厢会撞到你的后面。”但詹姆斯喜欢每个人都看到他闪亮的红色油漆，所以他减速了。最后一节车厢停了下来，撞到了其他滑行车厢的后面。
And basically, each slip coach car has this designated engineer. And that person would unhook the last car in the chain when they approach a target stop. And then they'd slowly bring in inferlambing and hit the brakes. Meanwhile, the rest of the train just keeps going. The guard had two controls, the slip lever and the brake.
突然，托帕姆·哈特爵士明白了。詹姆斯只是假装知道滑行车厢的事。“哦，詹姆斯，你最好小心点，这可能是你的终身监禁。”哦，是的，节目中没有错误是不受惩罚的。这正好说明了。做事真的只有两种方式：错误的方式或……正确的方式！
To prepare for the slipping to take place, the guard first had to remove the safety pin. And like any good railway changing of the guard moment, it drew a crowd. At best, preparations were being made to receive the slip coach. Using his brake, the guard brought the coach to a smooth standard adjacent to the castle. I mean, even with an engineer on hand to control the slip car, it seems incredibly delicate to detach from a speeding train. Yeah, there are literally a lot of moving parts to this whole thing, right? And so as you can imagine, there were incidents. Some of these were pretty mild, like a coach getting slipped by accident in the middle of nowhere
正确的方式！啊！啊！走吧！我们要去西区！我们要去西区！我们要去西区！我们要去西区！我们要去西区！我们要去西区！我们要去西区！我们要去西区！我们要去西区！
and then people getting stuck in the middle of nowhere. But in some cases, slipped cars would actually ram into the back of the train that dropped them off. So for instance, if a car was dropped off, but the rest of the train had to make an emergency stop, the car would just crash into the train itself. So is that why they stopped using them like accidents and things going wrong? Yeah, in part, but there were other factors too. For one thing, trains were getting faster, making the process more dangerous, and slipping
休息之后，库尔特带我们参观他最喜欢的新博物馆。猜猜是什么类型的博物馆。我们的下一站是纽约布鲁克林市中心的退役地铁站台。所以我最近去了一趟纽约市，和一些住在那里的一起工作的同事吃了晚饭，他们告诉了我这个我绝对必须看的交通博物馆。所以这接近《99%隐形》，我正在纽约交通博物馆，它讲述了地铁建设、地铁车厢、地铁旋转门的历史，但可能最引人注目的是，你基本上是从看起来像地铁站入口的地方进入的。事实上，我不得不想象有时人们走下那些台阶，以为他们要乘坐F线火车，结果发现有一个看起来像整个地铁站的博物馆。那是因为它实际上就是一个地铁站。它建于20世纪30年代，然后在70年代改建成了这个博物馆。
coaches was labor intensive. Not only did each slipped car need its own engineer, but they also had to have people reattaching the cars when they were getting picked back up, slipping only worked in one direction. Plus, for the system to work, passengers had to be locked in their individual compartments. And if they got in the wrong car, well, they had a long time to think hard about their mistake while stuck in that car, waiting to be slipped at the wrong station. And you'll never guess what show spent an entire episode teaching kids that
有来自大都会运输署（MTA）各个时代的轨道和火车。这真的很特别，你可以走过它们，看到复古的广告。那些是真实工作地铁轨道上真实火车上的真实广告。每年冬天，他们都会做所谓的“假日复古列车”，他们把来自不同时代的不同车厢拼凑在一起，你可以像乘坐普通的日常地铁一样乘坐它。这个地方太棒了，所以如果你像我一样是个火车迷，下次你在布鲁克林时，一定要去看看纽约交通博物馆。非常值得一停。我们今天的最后一站将是北卡罗来纳州的达勒姆。
very less. I'm guessing it's Thomas the Tank Engine. Right, of course it is. Hey attention, make sure you get into the right coach, the one that's stopping at your station. All aboard. I'll get you there on time with my brand new slip coaches. James was very pleased with himself. and new slip-clotters. BEEP! BEEP! BEEP! BEEP!
绰号“开罐器桥”，北卡罗来纳州达勒姆有一座铁路立交桥，因刮掉敢于从其轨道下方通过的卡车顶部而闻名。诺福克南方铁路格雷格森街立交桥的设计目的是允许高达12英尺左右的车辆安全通过，这在1940年建造时似乎绰绰有余。然而，多年来，卡车变得越来越高，越来越多的卡车撞上了这座桥。尽管实施了一系列明亮的标志、闪烁的灯光和其他警告，提醒司机车辆太高，即将被大声斩首。这些碰撞还是不断发生。一位名叫尤尔根·亨的当地居民在附近的一栋大楼里工作，当时他开始注意到涉及该桥的事故频率很高。这有时太疯狂了。我坐在办公桌前平静地工作，突然外面传来一声巨大的撞击声，我差点从椅子上摔下来。
James was very pleased with himself. But of course, something goes slightly wrong and things escalate. Prepare to un-couple the rear coach! Don't slow down too much in the station James, or the last coach will bump into the back of you. But James liked everyone to see his shiny red paint, so he slowed down. The last coach got stopped and bumped into the back of the other slip coaches.
2008年，他安装了一台摄像机来记录这些碰撞。从那时起，他已经拍摄并发布了100多个视频。这些短片捕捉到了令人愉悦的混乱光谱，至少对于那些倾向于基础设施幸灾乐祸的人来说是这样。特别高的卡车被桥完全挡住，像一个人撞到厨房橱柜一样弹回来。较矮的车辆带着痛苦的尖叫声滑过，在某些情况下，车辆的高度恰到好处，或者更确切地说是恰好错误，车辆的整个顶部像沙丁鱼罐头一样被剥开，因此得名“开罐器桥”。在观看了几十次这样的事故后，人们开始怀疑这样一个明显的问题怎么能这么久都没有得到解决。多年来，铁路、城市和州都采取了行动来减少涉及该桥的事故，但收效甚微。铁路部门安装了一根防撞梁，以防止卡车撞到桥本身，这保护了基础设施以及可能在上方行驶的任何货物和乘客，但对下方的卡车并没有多大帮助。可以理解的是，铁路公司的关注点不在于路上的卡车，而在于轨道上的火车。
Suddenly Sir Topham had understood. James had only pretended to know about slip coaches. Oh James, you better watch out, it might be life imprisonment for you. Oh yeah, and the show No Mistake goes unpunished. It just goes to show. There really are only two ways of doing things the wrong way or... The right way!
就达勒姆市而言，它安装了一系列补充警告机制，在桥前的三个交叉路口各设置了三个低净空标志。还竖立了一对较小的路边标志，标明高度限制为8英尺1英寸，这比实际限制减少了几英寸，以引入另一个安全缓冲。有一次，北卡罗来纳州还在桥前安装了一个超高闪烁标志，带有闪烁的橙色灯光。然而，卡车继续撞向横梁，因此该标志于2016年被移除，并替换为更高科技的超高必须转弯变体，配有LED显示屏，全部与传感器相连，以检测接近的超大车辆。该系统与新的交通灯集成，以便当传感器被触发时，红绿灯会变红。其想法是在卡车司机继续前进之前，给他们更多的时间来注意到警告标志。然而，尽管进行了这种更复杂的干预，这座桥继续夺走卡车。
The right way! Ah! Ah! Let's go! We're going to the West Side! We're going to the West Side! We're going to the West Side! We're going to the West Side! We're going to the West Side! We're going to the West Side! We're going to the West Side! We're going to the West Side! We're going to the West Side!
由于似乎没有任何警告是足够的，多年来考虑了其他解决方案，如抬高桥梁、降低街道或完全重定向卡车交通。铁路部门长期以来一直认为，抬高桥梁将需要在两侧进行重大的重新分级，可能耗资数百万美元。降低街道也被认为是不切实际的，因为一条污水总管直接在它下方运行，在桥前安装低净空杆或以其他方式将超高交通完全重定向到该区域之外也将具有挑战性。送货卡车需要能够直接开到桥前，然后转弯以便进入附近的一组餐馆。重新规划它们是不可行的。最终，经过多年的延误和推诿，2019年10月，一个工作组聚集在现场，做了不可思议的事情，抬高了桥梁。曾经的11英尺8英寸桥现在或多或少是一座12英尺4英寸的桥，根据新的道路侧面高度限制标志。虽然根据尤尔根·亨的测量，实际净空约为12英尺8英寸。为了50万美元的不那么低的成本，北卡罗来纳铁路公司尽可能地顶起了他们的轨道，而没有影响开罐器两侧附近的交叉路口。当然，这个高度仍然无法容纳每一辆卡车。该州允许高达13英尺6英寸的车辆。果然，在亨发布的一段视频中，就在这个修复措施启用几周后，一辆卡车的顶部被削掉了一块金属。几十年来，开罐器桥代表了财务限制、物理挑战和政治官僚主义的完美风暴，所有这些都密谋反对一个完整且永久的设计解决方案。即使现在桥已经抬高，它可能仍然被证明是一件有缺陷的基础设施和持续的滋扰。所有城市都有这样的东西，相互冲突的优先事项的错位副产品，绊倒公民或刮伤他们的车辆，但很少有像开罐器桥那样大、麻烦或在互联网上被广泛分享的。关于开罐器桥的故事首先出现在我们的书《99%隐形城市》中，由库尔特·科尔斯泰德和我罗曼·马尔斯撰写。你可以在世界各地以各种语言获得它，所以和你的当地书商谈谈，给自己买一本。《99%隐形》本周由库尔特·科尔斯泰德制作，雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳和马丁·冈萨雷斯参与，凯利·普兰编辑，原创音乐由斯旺·里奥创作，马丁·冈萨雷斯进行混音和声音设计。克里斯·布鲁贝扮演我们和蔼可亲的列车长，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。对于我们来说，团队包括杰森·迪利恩、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·李、拉什玛·道恩、乔·罗森伯格和我罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在，总部位于北边仅一站路的地方。
After the break, Kurt takes us on a tour of his new favorite museum. Guess which kind of museum it is. Our next stop is the De-Commission Subway Platform in downtown Brooklyn, New York. So I recently took a trip to New York City and met some of my NIA MPI colleagues who lived there for dinner and they told me about this transit museum which I absolutely had to see. So this is close to the 9% visible, and I am in the New York Transit Museum, and it tells the history of the subway construction,
休息过后，库尔特将带我们参观他最喜欢的新博物馆。猜猜看是什么类型的博物馆。我们的下一站是纽约布鲁克林市中心的退役地铁站台。最近我去了一趟纽约市，和住在那里的一些NIA MPI同事共进晚餐，他们向我介绍了这个我绝对必须参观的交通博物馆。这里离“9%可见”很近，我现在就在纽约交通博物馆里，它讲述了地铁建设的历史，
subway cars, subway turnstiles, but possibly the most remarkable thing about it is that you basically enter through what looks like the entrance to a subway station. In fact, I have to imagine that sometimes people walk down those steps thinking they're going to get the F-Train only to find that there's a museum that looks like a whole subway station. And that's because it was actually a subway station. It was built in the 1930s and then converted into this museum in the 70s.
地铁车厢、地铁闸机，但它最引人注目的地方可能在于，你基本上是从一个看起来像地铁站入口的地方进入的。事实上，我不得不想象，有时人们走下那些台阶，以为自己要去坐F线地铁，结果却发现这里有一个看起来像整个地铁站的博物馆。这是因为它确实曾经是一个地铁站。它建于20世纪30年代，后来在70年代被改建成这个博物馆。
There are tracks and there are trains from all eras of the MTA. It's really quite something and you can walk through them, see the vintage advertisements. And those are real ads on real trains on real working subway tracks. And every winter they do what's called the Hulledaden Estalgetrain, where they frank and stand together a train from a hodgepodge of different cars from different eras, which you can ride on like a normal everyday subway. The place is awesome, so if you're a train nerd like me the next time you're in Brooklyn, be sure to check out the New York Transit Museum. It's well worth a stop. Our final stop today will be in Durham, North Carolina.
这里有来自MTA各个时代的轨道和列车。这真的很棒，你可以穿过它们，看看复古的广告。那些都是在真正运行的地铁轨道上的真实列车里的真实广告。每年冬天，他们都会举办所谓的“假日复古列车”活动，他们将来自不同时代、不同车厢的列车拼凑在一起，你可以像乘坐日常地铁一样乘坐它。这个地方太棒了，所以如果你像我一样是个火车迷，下次去布鲁克林时，一定要去看看纽约交通博物馆。非常值得一游。我们今天的最后一站将是北卡罗来纳州的达勒姆。
Nick named the Can Opener Bridge, there is a rail overpass in Durham, North Carolina that has become famous for scraping the tops off of trucks that dare pass beneath its tracks. The Norfolk Southern Gregson Street overpass was designed to allow safe passage for vehicles up to around 12 feet tall, which probably seemed like more than enough overhead when it was constructed in 1940. Over the years, though, trucks got taller, and more and more trucks hit the bridge. Despite the implementation of a series of bright signs, flashing lights, and other warnings that the driver's two tall vehicle
在北卡罗来纳州的达勒姆，有一座被称为“开罐器桥”的铁路立交桥，它因刮掉敢于从其轨道下方通过的卡车顶部而闻名。诺福克南方铁路格雷格森街立交桥的设计初衷是允许高度在12英尺左右的车辆安全通过，这在1940年建造时似乎绰绰有余。然而，多年来，卡车变得越来越高，越来越多的卡车撞上了这座桥。尽管实施了一系列明亮的标志、闪烁的灯光和其他警告，提醒司机车辆过高，
is about to be loudly decapitated. These collisions just kept happening. A local resident named Yurgen Hen was working in a nearby building when he began to notice the high frequency of incidents involving the bridge. It's pretty crazy sometimes. I sit there at my desk working peacefully and all of a sudden there's this massive crash out there, and almost fall out of my chair.
即将被大声地“斩首”。这些碰撞事故还是不断发生。一位名叫尤尔根·亨的当地居民在附近的一栋大楼工作时，开始注意到涉及该桥的事故频率很高。这有时真的很疯狂。我坐在办公桌前平静地工作，突然外面传来一声巨大的撞击声，我差点从椅子上摔下来。
In 2008, he installed a video camera to document the collisions. Since then, he has captured and posted over 100 videos. These short films capture a delightful spectrum of mayhem, at least for those inclined towards infrastructural shot and Freud. Especially tall trucks are stopped entirely by the bridge and bounce back like a person hitting their head on a kitchen cabinet. Shorter vehicles slide under with just a painful screeching sound, and in some cases where the vehicle's height is just right or rather just wrong, the entire tops of the vehicles are peeled back like a sardine can, hence the name, the can open a bridge. After watching dozens and dozens of these incidents, one starts to wonder how such an
2008年，他安装了一台摄像机来记录这些碰撞。从那时起，他已经拍摄并发布了100多个视频。这些短片捕捉到了令人愉悦的混乱场面，至少对于那些倾向于从基础设施灾难中寻找乐趣的人来说是这样。特别高的卡车会被桥梁完全挡住，并像人撞到厨房橱柜一样反弹回来。较矮的车辆会伴随着刺耳的尖叫声滑过，而在某些情况下，如果车辆高度刚好，或者说刚好不对，整个车顶就会像沙丁鱼罐头一样被剥开，因此得名“开罐器桥”。在观看了几十次这样的事故后，人们不禁会想，这样一个
obvious problem can go unfixed for so long. The railroad, the city, and the state have all taken actions to reduce incidents involving the bridge over the years, and the state have all taken actions to reduce incidents involving the bridge over the years, but with limited success. The railroad installed a crash beam to keep trucks from hitting the bridge itself, and this protected the infrastructure and any freight and passengers that might be traveling overhead, but it didn't do a lot for the trucks down below. Understandably, the rail company's concern is not with the trucks on the road, but the trains on the rails.
明显的问题怎么能这么久都得不到解决。多年来，铁路公司、市政府和州政府都采取了行动来减少涉及该桥的事故，但收效甚微。铁路公司安装了一个防撞梁，以防止卡车撞到桥体本身，这保护了基础设施以及可能在上方行驶的任何货物和乘客，但对下方的卡车并没有太大帮助。可以理解的是，铁路公司的关注点不在路上的卡车，而在轨道上的火车。
For its part, the city of Durham installed a supplemental array of warning mechanisms, introducing three low clearance signs posted at each of three intersections in advance of the bridge. A pair of smaller roadside signs with a stated height limit of 8-1-1-1 inches were also put up, which shaved a few inches off the actual limit to introduce another safety buffer. At one point, the state of North Carolina also installed an over-height while flashing sign with blinking orange lights correctly in front of the bridge. Trucks however continued to crash into the beam, so the sign was removed in 2016 and
就达勒姆市而言，它安装了一系列补充性的警告机制，在桥前的三个交叉路口各设置了三个限高标志。还竖立了一对较小的路边标志，标明限高为8英尺11英寸，这比实际限高减少了几英寸，以引入另一个安全缓冲。有一次，北卡罗来纳州还在桥前安装了一个带有闪烁橙色灯光的超高警告闪烁标志。然而，卡车还是继续撞向防撞梁，所以该标志在2016年被移除，并
replaced with a higher tech over-height must turn variant coupled with an LED display, all linked with sensors to detect approaching oversized vehicles. The system was integrated with a new traffic light so that when the sensors were tripped, the stoplight would turn red. The idea was to give the truck drivers more time to notice the warning sign before plowing ahead. Despite this more sophisticated intervention, however, the bridge continued to claim in
替换为一个更高科技的“超高必须转弯”变体，并配有LED显示屏，所有这些都与传感器相连，以检测接近的超高车辆。该系统与新的交通灯集成在一起，当传感器被触发时，红绿灯会变红。其想法是让卡车司机在继续前进之前有更多时间注意到警告标志。然而，尽管进行了这种更复杂的干预，这座桥仍然继续“吞噬”
main trucks. Since no amount of warnings seemed sufficient, other solutions were considered over the years, like raising the bridge, lowering the street, or redirecting truck traffic entirely. The railroad long argued that raising the bridge would require significant regrading on both sides, potentially costing millions of dollars. Lowering the street was also deemed impractical because a sewer main runs directly below it, installing a low clearance bar in advance of the bridge or otherwise redirecting over right traffic away from the area entirely would be challenging too. Delivery trucks need to be
卡车。由于似乎没有任何警告是足够的，多年来人们考虑了其他解决方案，比如抬高桥梁、降低街道或完全改道卡车交通。铁路公司长期以来一直认为，抬高桥梁需要对两侧进行大量的重新平整，可能耗资数百万美元。降低街道也被认为是不切实际的，因为一条污水总管直接从其下方穿过，在桥前安装限高杆或以其他方式完全将超高交通引离该区域也具有挑战性。送货卡车需要
able to drive right up to the bridge then turn in order to access a set of restaurants nearby. Rewrouting them just is infeasible. Finally, after years of delays and buckpassing in October of 2019, a work crew converged on the site to do the improbable and raise the bridge. What was once the 11 foot 8 bridge is now more or less a 12 foot 4 bridge, according to the new road flanking height limit signs. Though according to Euricant Hens measurements, the actual clearance is around 12 feet 8 inches. For the not-so-low cost of half a million dollars, the North Carolina Railroad Company
能够直接开到桥边，然后转弯以进入附近的一系列餐馆。重新规划它们的路线是不可行的。最终，经过多年的延误和推诿，2019年10月，一个工作组聚集在现场，完成了不可能的任务，抬高了桥梁。根据新的道路侧面限高标志，曾经的11英尺8英寸桥现在或多或少变成了12英尺4英寸的桥。虽然根据尤尔根·亨的测量，实际净空高度约为12英尺8英寸。北卡罗来纳铁路公司花费了50万美元，
jacked up their tracks as much as they could without impacting nearby crossings on either side of the can opener. Of course, this height still won't accommodate every truck. The state allows vehicles up to 13 feet 6 inches. Sure enough, a metal chunk was clipped off the top of a truck in a video posted by him just a few weeks after this fix was enabled. For decades, the Cannot Opener Bridge has represented a perfect storm of financial limitations, physical challenges, and political bureaucracy all conspiring against a complete and permanent
尽可能地抬高了轨道，而没有影响到“开罐器”两侧附近的交叉路口。当然，这个高度仍然无法容纳所有卡车。该州允许车辆高度达到13英尺6英寸。果不其然，在这个修复措施启用仅几周后，尤尔根·亨发布的一段视频中，一辆卡车的顶部就被削掉了一块金属。几十年来，“开罐器桥”代表了财务限制、物理挑战和政治官僚主义的完美风暴，所有这些都阻碍了一个完整且永久的
design solution. Even now that the bridge has been raised, it may still prove to be a flawed piece of infrastructure and a persistent nuisance. All cities have things like this, ill-fitting byproducts of conflicting priorities that trip up citizens or scrape their vehicles, but few are as large, troublesome, or as widely shared on the internet as the can opener bridge. The story about the Cannot Opener Bridge first appeared in our book, The 99% Invisible City, by Kurt Colestet and me Roman Mars. You can get it in all kinds of languages all around the world, so talk to your local bookseller and get yourself copy. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Kurt Colestet, with Jacob Maldonado Medina and
设计解决方案。即使现在桥梁已经抬高，它可能仍然会被证明是一个有缺陷的基础设施和持续的麻烦。所有城市都有这样的东西，即相互冲突的优先事项产生的“不合身”副产品，绊倒市民或刮擦他们的车辆，但很少有像“开罐器桥”这样大、麻烦或在互联网上被如此广泛分享的。关于“开罐器桥”的故事首次出现在我们的书《99%不可见城市》中，作者是库尔特·科尔斯泰特和我罗曼·马斯。你可以在世界各地用各种语言买到它，所以去和当地的书商谈谈，给自己买一本吧。《99%不可见》本周由库尔特·科尔斯泰特制作，雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳和
Martinganzales, edited by Kelly Pran, original music by Swan Riau, mixed and sound design by Martín Gonzales. Chris Bruebe played our affable conductor, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. For us the team includes Jason Dillion, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lashma Dawn, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his below- logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM Podcast family. Now, headquartered just one barbed stop north
马丁·冈萨雷斯参与，凯利·普兰编辑，原创音乐由斯旺·里奥创作，马丁·冈萨雷斯负责混音和声音设计。克里斯·布鲁贝担任我们和蔼可亲的指挥，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。对于我们来说，团队成员包括杰森·迪利恩、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·李、拉什玛·道恩、乔·罗森伯格和我罗曼·马斯。《99%不可见》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在，总部位于北边仅一站路的地方
in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too.
在潘多拉大楼里。非常漂亮。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，或关注节目账号@99PI.org。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。
There's a new TikTok with Chris Barouba, you definitely should check out. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI, at 99PI.org. Thank you for riding with 99% invisible, stitcher and serious XM. All passengers must now disembark, as the train is about to be permanently locked away for a minor rules in fraction. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有一个关于克里斯·巴鲁巴（Chris Barouba）的新TikTok视频，你一定要去看看。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目链接，以及99PI的所有往期节目。感谢你收听《99%隐形》，感谢Stitcher和SiriusXM。所有乘客现在必须下车，因为列车即将因轻微违规而被永久封存。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。